as i stand here men women
and children are huddled in basements
across ukraine seeking protection
soldiers and citizens alike
have taken up arms to defend their land
and families
the sorrow we feel for their suffering
and admiration for their bravery
is only matched by the gratitude we feel
for the security in which we live
and what underpins that security
is the strength of our economy
it gives us the ability to fund the
armed forces we need to maintain our
liberty the resources we need to support
our allies the power to impose sanctions
which cause severe economic costs
and the flexibility to support
businesses and individuals through
crises as they emerge
but mr speaker
we should be in no doubt
behind putin's invasion is a dangerous
calculation
that democracies are divided politically
weak and economically insecure
incapable of making tough long-term
decisions to strengthen our economies
mr speaker this calculation is mistaken
what the authoritarian mind perceives as
division
we know
are the passionate disagreements at the
heart of our living breathing democracy
what they see as chaos we know is the
freedom to be dynamic and innovative
and what they call the inherent weakness
of open societies and free economies
we know is the source of our
strength
we will confront this challenge to our
values
not just in the arms and resources we
send to ukraine
but in strengthening our economy here at
home
so when i talk about security yes i mean
responding to the war in ukraine
but i also mean
the security of a faster growing economy
the security of more resilient public
finances
and security for working families as we
help with the cost of living
mr speaker
today's statement builds a stronger more
secure economy for the united kingdom
we have a moral responsibility to use
our economic strength to support ukraine
and working with international partners
to impose severe costs on putin's regime
we are supplying military aid to help
ukraine defend its borders providing
around 400 million pounds in economic
and humanitarian aid as well as up to
half a billion dollars in multilateral
financial guarantees
and launching the new homes for ukraine
scheme to make sure those forced to flee
have a route to safety here in the uk
and we are imposing sanctions of
unprecedented scale and scope
we sanctioned over a thousand
individuals entities and subsidiaries
frozen the assets of major russian banks
imposed punitive tariffs on t products
restricted russia's access to sterling
clearing to insurance to the uk's
capital market to swift and we've
targeted the russian central bank too
be in no doubt these sanctions
coordinated with our allies are working
the russian ruble plummeted to record
lows the moscow stock exchange has been
largely suspended for a month and the
central bank of russia has been forced
to more than double interest rates to 20
we warned
that an aggressive
unprovoked invasion would be met with
severe economic costs and it has
i'm proud to say as the whole house will
say
we stand with ukraine
[Music]
but mr speaker
the actions we have taken to sanction
putin's regime are not cost free for us
at home
the invasion of ukraine presents a risk
to our recovery as it does to countries
around the world
we came into this crisis with our
economy growing faster than expected
with the uk having the highest growth
rate in the g7 last year
but the obr has said specifically
there is unusually high uncertainty
around the outlook
it is too early
to know the full impact of the ukraine
war on the uk economy
but their initial view
combined with high global inflation and
continuing supply chain pressures
means the obr now forecasts growth this
year of 3.8 percent
the obr then expect the economy to grow
by 1.8
in 2023
and 2.1 1.8 and 1.7
in the following three years
the house will take comfort
that the lower growth outlook has not
affected our strong jobs performance
unemployment is now forecast to be lower
in every year of the forecast
it is already at 3.9 back to the low
levels we saw before the pandemic
but mr speaker
the war's most significant impact
domestically is on the cost of living
covid in global factors meant goods and
energy prices were already high
statistics published this morning show
that inflation in february was 6.2
percent
lower than the us and broadly in line
with the euro area
disruptions to global supply chains and
energy markets combined with the
economic response to putin's aggression
mean the obr expect inflation to rise
further averaging 7.4 percent this year
as i said last month
the government will support the british
people as they deal with the rising
costs of energy
people should know
that we will stand by them as we have
throughout the last two years